[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
families
friends esteemed faculty and staff
welcome to yale college class day
and most importantly to the class of
2021
on behalf of me sky steven jyn and
stanley
we just want to say congratulations
for over 100 years yalies have come
together and
celebrated our graduating class one last
time on class day
i don't need to tell you that this
year's ceremony much like our senior
year
looks a little different from its
predecessors but in today's festivities
we hope to replicate and renovate
many of yale's most cherished traditions
we'll start today off with a series of
speeches
from graduates and alumni vtran will
open our ceremony with the ivy ode
then we'll hear from acclaimed
songwriter bobby lopez
our senior class counsel and a comedic
reflection by matt nadel and tayava
torres dasa
to cap off the day and our time at yale
alex the bornak will deliver a
reflection on these last four years
we've shared together
but before we begin i wanted to take a
moment to walk you through some of the
items you received yesterday
the class anthology produced by skyward
details our time together in a series of
essays and works of art
the church warden pipe a tradition that
dates back to the 1860s
used to symbolize the end of a carefree
college life
as successive generations of yalies
would form circles and crush the pipes
into the earth
the sprig of ivy ties us back to the
ceremonial planting of the class
ivy a tradition that began way back in
1852
to symbolize the abiding legacy of our
contributions to the college
even long after we graduate and lastly
the yale handkerchief which sky will
tell you more about at the end of our
ceremony here today
yale has changed a lot since these
traditions first began it's even changed
in the few short years that we've been a
part of it
but there are some parts of it that will
always remain constant
here to remind us of this enduring
spirit of yale
is vitran a senior in brantford college
studying ethnicity race and migration
with our iv owed there's a specific
feeling of coming back to campus after
being gone for a while
sometimes it's been a long uber ride
from hartford or laguardia or jfk
sometimes it's an uber ride after a
train ride into union station
sometimes it's in a car your family's
driving in that you've known your entire
life
sometimes it's the car you're driving in
with your friends coming back from a
trip you're still trying to revel in
and your body is itching to get up
because you've been sitting for hours
and pulling through chapel or york or
elm you know the streets but they also
feel a little bit different this time
it's the same feeling of walking into
your childhood home after six months in
new haven and swearing that your head is
a tiny bit closer to the ceiling
it's the same feeling as hugging your
family again and wanting to show them
that you're a little bit different
but that you're also the same
there's a specific feeling of hearing a
voice you love pop up in your comment
room
it's thursday and you hear your sweet
door open and close and you think it's
your suite mate just coming back from
the bathroom but it's actually
someone else there's a specific joy at
hearing a voice that isn't coming out of
your computer speakers
it's the same feeling as hearing one of
your favorite songs start to play at a
party
remember those or on the radio in the
car or on your friend's phone that's
connected to the bluetooth speaker in
the living room
and as many times as i've heard carrie
underwood's before he cheats or sees the
gemini's gas pedal
the songs never don't hit
it's the same feeling as hearing that
one of your friends got that job they
were excited for and you are so excited
for everything that's coming their way
there's a specific feeling of seeing one
of your favorite people on cross campus
looking cute and all
you see someone you're pretty sure is
who you think it is but especially now
with masks i really don't know if we're
on the high level or if we're on the
walk past each other and act like we're
looking at something over their level
but sometimes it really is someone you
know and love
and can be excited for fun fashionably
and they're excited to see you too
it's the same feeling as seeing red chat
pop up
in your zoom because someone has dm'd
you
and it's the feeling of watching your
friends smile at your message in
response
or both of you covering your faces and
turning your cameras off because you're
laughing at the wrong thing at the wrong
time
it's the same feeling as losing your
person at a party or a weird yale event
that you're much more socially anxious
about than you're willing to admit
but then you turn around and you see
them and they were looking for you too
a while ago i was coming back from
retreat with a wonderful group of people
and on the way back to new haven someone
was like what if x person
had come do you think that would have
made any difference
and then someone was like of course they
always make it everyone makes a
difference
and i think about that a lot because
especially in a place like yale it's so
easy to think
that you could go missing for a few days
and no one would notice
and every other day for the past four
years i thought about disappearing to go
live on a farm
and paint and read books and sit with
goats
but if there's anything i've learned at
yale it's that
i am only a sum of everyone that i've
ever loved
no one here knows what they're doing or
who they are or what they want in life
the things that we think are worth it
and the things that we're taught
will satisfy us and the job and this
salary and all these other things that
we think yale is supposed to be for
don't make yale when in reality the
things that make yale yale are the
people that we love and the ways that we
love them
we look forward to the little things
with them we look forward to seeing if
there's bacon at brunch
if your house favorite will win the
bachelor they don't
if that thing you ordered has finally
come into the packaging center
and if it's finally going to be nice
enough this weekend to go to the farmers
market and rooster with your friends
like you always say you want to
and in truth life a week from now could
be exactly the same
or drastically different and while we
don't always know what we're doing
we do know what we feel we feel happy
and sad and stressed and exhausted and
tired of the snow
and tired of the cold we feel joy and
pride
and love and loneliness and like we're
growing up too
fast
but if you look outside
there's a specific feeling of leaving
campus
after being here for a while and when i
next see elm street i will feel
older there's that weird conversation
starter that's like if you could say
anything to your younger self what would
you say
and i think i would say i'm so proud
we've come so far and done so much and
loved
so widely and so deeply and there's even
more to come
it's the same feeling as packing up your
suitcase for the end of the semester
or the end of yale now and realizing
that you're not the same person you were
when you came here freshman year
it's the same feeling as taking down all
your photos and all your posters off
your wall and thinking
i'm gonna miss this place
there's a specific feeling of leaving
campus after being here for a while
and i think it's called growing up and
leaving home
and i wouldn't want to do it anywhere
else
much love to the class of 2021 love
y'all
we did it we are delighted to announce
our renowned class day speaker
robert lopez yale college class of 1997.
lopez is a two-time emmy grammy
oscar and tony award-winning songwriter
after graduating from yale college in
1997 with a bachelor's degree in english
he joined the bmi musical theater
workshop
where he met future collaborators jeff
marks with whom he co-created the
multiple tony award-winning avenue q and
kristen anderson
now kristen anderson lopez his wife and
co-writer
the couple's partnership produced the
songs from frozen frozen 2
and marvel's wand division as well as
the song remember me from coco
lopez is also the co-creator with matt
stone
and trey parker of south park fame of
the book of mormon which debuted in 2011
and won nine tony awards he shared two
emmy awards for his music on
nickelodeon's the wonder pets
as well as emmy nominations for songs in
scrubs
the 87th academy awards ceremony and the
mockumentary the comedians
his work has been featured on the
television shows south park
the simpsons and phineas and ferb lopez
is one of only 15 artists to win
all four major entertainment industry
awards
emmy grammy oscar and tony he was also
the youngest to do so at age 39
in 2014 and the first to win all four a
second time
he's been an amazing ambassador for the
artistic talents
and activities that are such a big part
of the yale experience
without further ado please help me
welcome robert lopez
hello congratulations and happy class
day yale college class of 2021.
i want to thank president salovey and
everyone at yale for the honor of
speaking to you today
actually this is going to be taped over
many days and i have a lot of these
shirts so i think that
we will be fine with the illusion of
continuity
so my class day in 1997 it rained and we
all sat in chairs for hours with
umbrellas which is something i've never
done since
i hope it doesn't rain today but if it
does please take my advice and don't be
talked into sitting outside
even with an umbrella you will still get
wet
my name is robert lopez everyone calls
me bobby
i'm a songwriter and i'm here because
the administration and the class day
committee now prefers
musical theater professionals to the
typical intellectual
historian politician writer or
entrepreneur they usually get
and well they should because at this
crossroads of history a little musical
theater might be just the thing for all
of us
and they hinted not so subtly that i
work some songs into my remarks
and for the majority of you who are like
who the f is this guy
here is a hint this is a rewrite of one
of my songs to forever musicalize the
moment president salovey asked me
to do this do you want to speak on class
day
i think it would be fun
i know it's not your superpower to talk
for half an
hour in front of everyone
but it would be exciting and just think
of
all the lessons you'd like to teach
yes i guess i'll speak on class day
[Music]
today is class day it's a celebration of
the four years you've spent at yale
new haven's changed a lot since my class
day 24 years ago
mostly it's better really the only thing
i miss is the yankee doodle
an old-fashioned lunch counter that
served magical burgers and fried
buttered doughnuts
god that place was great i'd go in the
early early morning for breakfast
sandwiches after pulling an all-nighter
the only time i ever got to hang out
with people from the crew team
i'll never forget there was this one all
nighter i pulled
i was writing some paper and my i left
my computer on
i used to really go through despair
while writing long papers and i needed
food to sustain my spirits
so i came back to my room with a soda
and a bag of chips
and i sat back down at my desk and where
my paper had left off
there were now like a bunch of random
letters like x d
f g k l semicolon
i thought that's weird and then i
noticed that some tissues from a box on
my desk had been shredded
then i looked at my window and there was
some loose dirt
and an acorn there and then
right on the ledge of the open window a
squirrel sat there
tensely looking back at me i screamed a
blood-curdling sound that probably woke
up the entire building
and the squirrel jumped out the window
onto a tree branch and never returned
honestly i thought about this a lot and
i
think it was a disney moment that i was
too high strung at the time to really
appreciate
i mean i was stuck on a paper and a
freaking squirrel
came in and typed something on my
keyboard
and i just screamed and deleted what he
typed i mean can you imagine
the song that the squirrel would
eventually have sung if i'd only thanked
him and let him stay
anyway i think the gist of what i want
to talk about today is accepting help
from the squirrel friends that the
universe provides
accepting collaboration into your life
the week before my class day we had
something called senior week
i'm not sure if you guys were able to
have that this year but back in my day
you were supposed to take a fun
trip with your best friends to like
myrtle beach and party all week
i was in the acapella group the spitz
winks and i and my two best friends from
my class in the winx john and brian
were sort of late to figure out what we
were going to do and we ended up going
to maine
which in may that year was really cold
and really damp
the cabin we rented had a sign bearing
its name which was it'll do
and as we sat and froze and did jigsaw
puzzles
the whole thing felt like a bit of a
metaphor for what we thought life was
about to serve us
i think we were afraid we were going to
graduate and go our separate ways and
forget each other
and that the real world was going to be
like it'll do in may 97
cold damp and depressing i think we were
afraid we'd be lonely
that it was about to be me against the
world
well first of all i could not have
gotten through this pandemic without
john and brian
every tuesday for the last year we got
on zoom and had a scotch and helped each
other deal with whatever we had to deal
with
we've been to each other's weddings
we've watched our kids be born
i mean a lot of my yale friends and i
have stuck together and worked together
too
and the real world may be tough but it
was not lonely
sometimes school with grades and tests
makes you feel like work is something
you do alone
but my experience is that work can't be
done without collaborators
i'm gonna talk out of my butt for a
moment a great surgeon has a team of
doctors and nurses in the operating room
with them
a ceo has to manage vice presidents and
satisfy the board of directors
a professor works within their
department a great novelist allows a
trusted circle of friends and ultimately
an editor to read early drafts and give
them necessary feedback
you get the idea i don't think there is
any field you can go into
in which you can succeed without working
with others
you guys have had collaborators your
whole life without knowing it
your first collaborators were your
family when you were a baby
you were totally dependent on your
parents but without knowing it you were
teaching them too
testing them through your utter
dependence forcing them to learn
responsibilities and solve problems and
gain skills they never would have
learned without a crying baby
helping them to level up to be able to
parent a toddler then a child
then a tween then a teen and now finally
twenty-something you and your family
work together to raise you
to get you into yale and get you out of
yale they are incredible collaborators
and they deserve credit for you as much
as you do for them
you guys should thank each other today
your classmates here at yale are
collaborators too
you've worked in the residential
colleges together making life better for
each other
you've worked together to plan events
like parties and dances and protests
you've worked together on sports teams i
didn't do that at yale
you've worked together in acapella
groups in theater did both of those
in newspapers comedy groups political
clubs
ethnic religious and racial identity
forums lgbtq plus
even secret societies all of these
things are examples of collaboration
you've been practicing it this whole
time
and when i was preparing for the speech
i met with the faculty member and the
student committee for class day
and i realized another thing you've been
collaborating on
reimagining yale within the realities of
covet
you guys know much more about what
that's been like than i do
and from what i've heard it's been very
difficult and stressful
but i just want to underline how much
collaborative work
it's taken you all to make this past
year a reality
and i want to say i'm amazed by it
i feel like sometimes the subtext of
education is
become well-rounded be skilled in
everything
don't have weaknesses be a road scholar
be incredible which i think in many ways
is a great message
and that it leads to you working to
better yourself which is really
important
but at some point you know everyone has
weaknesses
it's called being human after you
graduate you may struggle in the real
world for a few years
i certainly did i bumped up big time
into my weaknesses
i tend to be shy and introvert my
daughter says i'm infp
my wife says i'm a typical pisces and
when i graduated the buzzword for how to
get ahead was
networking everyone said network network
network
which to me sounded awful the thought of
going to cocktail parties and walking up
to people and giving them my card
i would just rather do anything other
than that
my other weakness was that i still
wasn't fully baked as a songwriter
since i was 13 years old i have been
writing songs that were very good but
very good imitations of stephen sondheim
like this one
ladies and gentlemen i've got wonderful
news for you we're about
to start i didn't yet have a voice of my
own
so even if i did give someone my card or
my demo tape and they heard my songs
they'd be like
that's great it sounds like steven
sondheim
it's okay to have weaknesses
it's okay to be shy it's okay to not be
fully baked as a songwriter
it's okay to have a hard time writing a
25 minute long speech
because if you find community and if you
find collaborators
you can partner with people who are
strong in the areas you struggle in
i joined a class that taught musical
theater writing called
the bmi musical theater workshop and my
classmates in that class
became my friends and collaborators and
helped me find my voice as a writer
my collaborator jeff marks was the kind
of person who thrived on networking
who loved promoting our team and never
felt self-conscious handing anyone a
demo tape
writing in the same room with jeff
brought out a different side of my
personality
one that was more like who i was making
jokes and laughing with the spizz wings
at yale
so instead of my default which was to
write like sondheim
i ended up having a lot more fun and
what we wrote
came out fresher and more real and
together
we wrote a show that was inspired by a
lot of the feelings we were both having
struggling in the real world and that
show went to broadway
in that show avenue q a puppet has just
graduated college
and is standing on the stage in cap and
gown holding his degree
he is meant to be just like you guys
except a little bit lamer
his name is princeton
what do you do with the ba
in english what is my life
going to be
four years of college and plenty of
knowledge have earned me this useless
degree
i can't pay the bills yet
cause i have no skills yet
the world is a big scary place
but somehow i can't shake
the feeling i might make
a difference to the human
[Applause]
race
i think in this moment of commencement
and a new chapter of life beginning for
all of you
there's also the illusion of a starter
pistol going off and a mad dash
to market yourself and sell what you
have and what you are
and there's a lot of truth to this
metaphor and a lot of what's great about
america lies in that race
and the spirit of trying to outshine the
competition and sparkle the brightest
many if not all of you are indeed
special sparkly diamonds discovered by
the yale admissions department
and cut and polished by four years of
education now looking to be set in
gorgeous fine jewelry
some of you may prefer a more masculine
image and you can feel free to invent
that on your own
at any rate what i'm trying to say is
that talent craft and ability
need to be channeled into purpose
of course you were all talented in your
particular way or you wouldn't be here
for me i tried to write the cleverest
lyrics with puns and jokes and inner
rhymes
i would search for new chords i'd never
heard before in a song
musical flourishes and crazy rhythms
that would stand out
and now when i listen to that old stuff
i cringe because it's just all about
trying to attract attention and show off
the subtext of it was hire me
it was an immature way of writing and it
had no purpose
beyond itself the true purpose of music
is not to serve yourself but
give something real and emotional to
your fellow human being
and i learned this not from my parents
not from a teacher
not from a friend but from a paper i
wrote about shakespeare's tempest in my
senior year of yale
this was my senior thesis in english and
i promise you i did not approach it
with the idea of learning anything i was
just trying to fulfill the requirement
get my degree and get on with it
so in the tempest there's a character
named prospero a powerful magician
who lives in exile on an island and he
has the servant named ariel who is sort
of a fairy spirit made of air
prospero sends ariel out to do his
magical bidding and influence the other
characters on the island
his purpose being complicated but
basically to redeem himself
by creating harmony in the lives of the
other characters
and ariel is always singing and in many
ways represents music
in my research i found that in the
renaissance the line between
academic professor and magician was
blurry
as was the line between music and magic
and i came across the work of a
renaissance philosopher named facino
who was famous for singing magical songs
and whose idea was that music
was a form of airy spirit kind of like
ariel
that could fly between the singer and us
and
influence our own spirits because both
were made of the same thing
air the word inspire itself was very
central to all of this
anyway i don't think it was a great
paper
i didn't even pick it up to see my grade
or read the comments because i was kind
of ashamed of how half-baked it was
but for the rest of my life every time
i've sat down to write a song
it's never been about trying to get
hired or getting noticed
i think about the magic power that music
has to heal
to inspire to influence to ensnare
all those things that prospero could do
music can do
and ever since i started doing that ever
since i started trying to reach out with
music
and help people with it like magic i
started being more successful
i think this is true of anything any of
you want to do in life
it needs to be of service to the
community it needs to fulfill a function
to make people's lives better in some
way
if it does that people will value it and
people will value you
kristin and i were thinking about this
idea when we wrote the song remember me
from coco
the first time we heard it the first
time we hear it in the movie the great
ernesto de la cruz is singing a farewell
to the audience
showing off for the ladies and hamming
it up remember
that kind of thing but later we hear
spoiler alert that the song was not
written by ernesto
but by a poor musician named hector that
was forced to leave his wife and little
daughter
when he went on the road and wrote her a
lullaby
to make sure she always knew he always
loved her even when
he was away remember
me though i have to say goodbye
remember me
don't let it make you cry for even if
i'm far away
i hold you in my heart i sing a secret
song
to you each night we are apart
remember me
though i have to travel far remember
me each time you hear
a sad guitar know that i'm with you
the only way that i can be
until you're in my arms again
remember
me
[Music]
so when you sit down to work on
something with someone what's the worst
thing that can happen
is it that the work goes badly that you
waste a few hours or even a whole day
making something you aren't proud of or
is it that
you might hurt the feelings of the
person you're working with
so the rule i had always operated by
which seemed logical to my ambitious
driven stressed out yale brain was that
the most important thing when you sit
down to write a song
is the song as long as the song turns
out great
anything goes which meant for me and my
collaborators
we had to have any power struggle
painful criticism or
knock-down drag-out fight that could
help the song
things took as long as they took and our
feelings weren't important
and operating by this rule i wrote lots
of good songs with lots of great people
but i noticed that those collaborations
tended to run into trouble
long term when bad feelings would
accumulate over time
so one day kristen and i were writing a
song on a particular project
and we were having our usual fight for
control and i told myself
today kristen matters more than this
song i won't stifle myself creatively
but i won't fight for anything
and we'll try every idea that everyone
has who cares if you write a bad song
so kristen said i want to use the four
chords of awesome
for those of you who don't know those
are the pop hit chords the one
five minor six four
and i had never allowed us to use them
because i thought they were like musical
msg just
too easy but today we were going to try
every idea and i knew she was going for
something
and this is what we wrote when i decided
to treat kristen
as more important than the song we were
writing
let it go let it go
i am one with the wind and sky
let it go let it go
you'll never see me cry
here i stand and
here i'll stay let the storm reach on
my power flurries through the air into
the ground
my soul is spiraling in frozen fractals
all around and one thought crystallizes
like an
icy blast
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
that song was more fun to write than
anything we'd ever written
it was a joyful happy process and it
allowed christmas perspective as an
artist and a feminist to change the
world a teeny bit
the people you work with are always more
important than the work you're doing
there is only benefit when you value
them that way
so i've talked a lot today about
collaboration
i hope it's been helpful and i hope you
go out there and knock our socks off
i know you will like everything else
i've ever done
i had help with this and i want to end
by thanking everyone who helped me get
this speech together
yale and president salovey for asking me
to do it
allison coleman and the students on the
class day committee who coached me on it
my friends my family my kids and
especially
my closest collaborator my partner and
wife
kristen anderson lopez no kristin no
speech
and finally that squirrel from my dorm
room
well it's taken me 24 years but to thank
him
i have finally memorialized him with his
own disney style song
where he sings his message to me and i'd
like to sing it now for you
to close this out as sort of a squirrely
benediction
on what has been an amazing day
don't give up when you're stuck
take my help what the f
i may be just a squirrel but damn it
girl i'll help you through
help me help you don't be
above collaboration
after your graduation
be someone else a squirrel give that
tale a swirl and help them
to help them help you
you've been through more than anyone
ill college class of 21
[Music]
bright college years with pleasure
life the shortest gladdest
years of life now go into the world
but do it squirled you'll sail right
through
if you help them
hello class of 2021 i'm brian owens your
class secretary
and i'm curtis calvit your class
treasurer and we are both very excited
to share this day with you
class of 2021 what a privilege it's been
to be the historic largest class
ever to enter yale college we are
essentially the vanguard of a new era
at yale a new era not because yale is
fundamentally changed but because it has
grown
to become more inclusive more accessible
and to offer more opportunity for all
case in point even in 2017 when we were
freshmen
durfee market expanded its meal swipe
from eight dollars
to nine dollars and many other wonderful
changes and developments have been
happening all around us we were the
first
class to live all four years in ben
franklin and pauly murray colleges
simultaneously facilities all around
campus have been expanding
and shifting their roles schwartzman
center which has been closed
essentially since we've been here will
nonetheless open very soon
to students for generations to come
science hill
has all kinds of new facilities for
state-of-the-art research
the tobin economic center will soon open
the future of yale looks really bright
and it's a privilege to have been one of
the first classes to experience yale in
this new phase
when we think back to yale we will
inevitably remember the trials and
tribulations
of the past four years and especially of
the past year and a half
our class braved this once in a century
pandemic
and we've grown resilient because of it
we created ways to ensure that social
distancing
does not mean becoming anti-social
let's catch up after the pandemic became
the new let's grab a meal sometime
and we survived months of zoom lectures
lying in bed
half awake camera off and microphone
muted
and this weekend we're going to be
saying goodbye to our time living in
these 14 residential colleges
the memories and the friendships are
going to last a lifetime but this
constant closeness of being together in
one
nice beautiful town is is going away
we'll remember the professors who have
shaped our lives
the faculty and staff who have taken
care of us and
all those conversations that we had at
random times in the day and night
being in the basement of bass and being
in the slightly less dark
upstairs of bass possibly even walking
down
what mark twain once called the most
beautiful street in america hill house
avenue
many of us will feel a wistful emptiness
as we lose our core identity of being a
yell student
that our connections with yale will only
grow stronger as we
build our new identities as yale alumni
we will join
a group of people dedicated to service
leadership
and education and if there's anything
that kovit has taught us
it is that we are all in this together
so please
stay in touch with the people who have
touched your lives
and at the same time make new friends at
your regional yield clubs and alumni
interest groups
even consider becoming a mentor to the
next classes of yales
and of course we welcome you to join us
at our class of 2021
alumni events we hope to see you there
we'd like to take one last second to
thank the family and friends
who devoted their time and energy to
making us into the adults that we are
today
they've shaped the class in 2021 in so
many wonderful ways
we'd also like to thank yale
administration for sticking with us in
this difficult year
and helping us to make the most out of
it for ensuring that we had a safe
fun and memorable senior year but above
all
it's been our pleasure to serve as your
senior class offices
officers once again congratulations
and good luck to the class of 2021
hey everyone obviously harvard yale is
one of the best weekends of the year
and some of my fondest memories from
first year actually with and helping
lauren
was waiting in line for the bus to the
stadium for
over an hour and i may or may not have
ordered and cancelled three or four
ubers
it's just one of those yield traditions
that really brings everyone together
you look up when you're sitting in the
student section and realize that you're
part of this amazing community and that
you have so much to be grateful for
and of course we all missed it this year
but we will for sure be back next
remembering that the weekend is a
marathon and not a sprint
[Music]
i have the pleasure of introducing this
year's speakers to the comedic
reflection
tiava torres de sal from harper college
is graduating with a bachelor of science
in mathematics
matt nadel also from hopper college is
graduating with a bachelor of arts in
american studies
which he insists is just as employable
as math the two of them wrote the speech
in their dark basement apartment
fueled by an unending passion for the
class of 2021
and a group of friends who contributed
jokes and offered edits on every draft
when asked about their writing process
matt and tayala said we wrote many jokes
and to the relief of the classic
committee only some of them are in the
speech
but i have to say having seen the two of
them work together on the speech
the only thing that's stronger than the
jokes you're about to hear is their
obvious love for each other as
suitemates
so with that i'll turn it over to matt
and tayava to deliver this year's
comedic reflection
president salovey dean chung esteemed
administrators and faculty
yale friends and family and members of
the class of 2021
today is a day for pride pride in our
alma mater
pride in our classmates and pride in
ourselves
i for one am a proud latino yale child
of immigrants who made his way to the
ivy league against all odds and i
am
yeah i'm actually just going to go matt
come back you so much to be proud of
um you're a great student uh you're
funny you're a pillar of the lgbt
community
you think i'm a pillar it's good to have
you back
matt and i have known each other for
quite some time in fact we met on august
25th
2017 the first day of our first year at
yale
we were randomly assigned roommates
coming to hill from opposite sides of
the country
i'm sure you remember the excitement of
meeting your first year roommate
your dad was in the common room putting
together a sonde bakken from ikea
your mom was disinfecting every bathroom
in bingham hall and you were beginning a
lifelong friendship that would
definitely never become hostile
i certainly remember it for me and matt
it was love at first sight
i mean tinder ship data match
forget em if you really want to find
love put your faith in jeremiah quinlan
and the yale housing algorithm
to clarify we're not actually lovers
we're best friends
in fact a few months after meeting matt
i started dating his best friend
and we've been together ever since boy
has that been convenient for the three
of us
yup the three of us all three of us
convenient for all three of us equally
unlike tayava i didn't have the good
fortune of finding true love in my first
year at yale
i trust we've all seen to all the boys
i've loved before
my love life was more like to all the
boys i've met at woods who
puked on my rug and cried about their ex
in my bed
i mean clearly one in four is not enough
oh matt come on it's their loss
you're a catch thank you you know i have
to admit
i was jealous our first semester when i
opened rumpus and
saw tayava on the 50 most beautiful
people at yale list
but now i understand my worth i may not
be 50 most hot
but i'm a haas family library hot
which is sterling frumpy and bass cafe
basic but ctl sexy
oh the cto where i pulled an all-nighter
and had a meltdown in front of my foot
leader
foot i almost forgot yale's favorite
cult providing fertilizer to the
appalachian trail since 1701
you know i almost did foot but i
actually broke my foot i'm sad you never
got to meet your footies right
but you know i did get to meet my froco
group
and my tf and my ula and my cce and my
che and my pl peer liaison my pl
personal library and of course my ssri
selective serotonin reality
summer science research institute yes
sir
and speaking of science can i hear it
for all my pre-meds out there
look at you with your lab coats and
employable skills
i know you're at home but if you're
pre-med i want you to raise your hand
proud great now please keep your hand up
if you are available for free or
low-cost tutoring
i am still trying to finish my science
credit now now now matt's modest so
here's something he won't tell you
he's an amazing student since meeting
that i now have
an organized calendar better study
habits and
crippling imposter syndrome you know
what i'm talking about
now if you really want to make us
normies feel comfortable on this campus
all they need to do is put people like
matt in standalone singles and not let
them speak in sections and just to
piggyback off that
i had some tough nights at you i'm sure
you did too
but in those moments of despair we must
remember
we have a resource the good life center
feeling down play in a sandbox
accidentally called your professor mom
touch a succulent submitted fan fiction
instead of an essay
hawk santo says chai on tap and you know
elsa yale's got your back
who will be there for you day and night
your personal librarian your personal
library in fact i oh
should i mad she's gonna love it i
actually wrote a poem in honor of my
personal librarian
so um lori broners this haiku is for you
orbis was no help needed newspaper
records
emailed you midnight please help that
great failed class no job law school dad
pride
right you didn't like it i would
critique your poetry but i haven't read
a book since i was 10 years old
what i expected to read books at yale i
expected i'd spend hours reading the
most prolific authors
in history william shakespeare virginia
woolf toni morrison
but instead i spent hours reading covic
emails from melanie boyd
marvin chun and stephanie spangler and
that's not yale's only false promise
yale tells you that you'll meet the next
john kerry or meryl streep
but you're much more likely to meet
their art major grandchild
in a pregame you weren't invited to yeah
i expected to meet the rich and famous
but all i've gotten is a six dollar
venmo request from a billionaire's child
for francia
of course the biggest broken promise
came on our first day at yale
in a speech in woolsey hall dean chun
told us not to worry about getting
straight a's you can get a couple b's
and c's
but what he didn't anticipate is that
we'd all be getting
peas thank you no fail yale the pandemic
has indeed presented many obstacles but
we've adapted our senior year to zoom
we've gone to zimprov shows and zoga
classes zaked parties and
disciplinary hearings but most of all
we've gone to zale zental health and
zounsling
group therapy of course we missed out on
a lot of senior traditions
society parties masquerade last chance
dance
but if there's one senior tradition
that's endured these tough times
it's fab club you know what we're
talking about and in our apartment we
found ourselves celebrating
march club april club and we are in the
midst of a
thrilling may club right now right now
but here's the thing even when we're
seniors no more
there's a club to which we will all
belong
the yale club where for a thousand
dollars a night you can get a new york
city hotel room that reminds you of a
welch single so
when your tonys cure your patience save
the world
the class of 2021 will scatter the globe
after we leave campus
but we will always be united in our
memories we will always be the class
that paid full tuition to watch a
sterling professor
speak on mute for 15 minutes will always
be the class that lost
commons wall street pizza and of course
myrtle beach which no one would go to
against covid regulations
right and we'll always be the class that
made it out in one piece
with the same top-of-the-line education
our predecessors enjoyed
and some top-of-the-line mrna they
couldn't have imagined
thank you
when i think about the student
organizations here i think about family
and camaraderie
i also think about the ways in which we
all come together from such diverse
backgrounds to unite the same passions
and interests
for me i've met some of my dearest and
closest friends throughout my time in
these organizations
and i'll forever be grateful for that
for me two organizations of standout in
particular are dance works and yale
stepping out
these are two organizations that are
part of the greater dance community here
at yale
and i'll really remember every single
rehearsal and performance i've done in
these groups
because these have really helped me
cultivate deeper and meaningful
connections with people
and i also think that there's something
so beautiful but the energy that's
created every single time there's a
performance
because it's such a safe and welcoming
space and i'll really miss that
[Music]
think back on your past four years at
yale did they turn out the way you
expected
how has yale changed you and how have
you changed yale
and are you proud of what you've made of
your four years here
as you listen to the final speech of
this year's class a program
i encourage you to consider and reflect
on your own college years
and what it means for you to be a yali
without further ado i'm beyond excited
to present to you this year's serious
reflection
given by alexa bornak a humanities major
of ezra styles college
my first winter break at yale i flew to
hawaii with my improv group on tour
and on our third day as we were coming
back from an adventure to a roaring
waterfall
we happened to stumble upon a rainbow
immediately
we pulled over got out of the car and as
if on cue all started sprinting towards
it
cheering and jumping and throwing our
fists in the air like we were crazy
we ran towards what felt like the
perfect ending to the perfect day
but as we tried getting closer and
closer the rainbow kept slipping further
away from us
three winter breaks have come and gone
since that tour but the memory feels
especially relevant now
each of us has spent the past four years
running towards
our beautiful yale finales every 1 a.m
paper and baths
every late night grilled cheese in the
buttery every performance every game
every test has been another step closer
to our senior springs
to a colorful time that's supposed to be
saturated with friends and parties and
graduation
and then came the pandemic and a lot of
things changed about yale
no more in-person classes no harvard
yale no masquerade
no spring fling it's hard not to focus
on all the loss
it's hard not to feel like just when we
are finally going to reach our rainbow
it slipped away
but the more i think about it the more i
realize it's always been this way
even before the pandemic from the moment
we first set foot on campus
there's always been things that we
wanted to do but couldn't
in fact there are whole boards filled
with them you can't go more than a
hundred feet without running into one of
these giant rectangular bulletin boards
on campus
inside outside old campus cross campus
even behind toads and each is filled to
the brim
with an array of glistening flyers and
posters
in our first years my friends and i
would stand in front of those boards
forever
taking photos of all the things that we
wanted to do improvaganza treasures from
the yale film archive
talk like a pirate day wilderness first
aid course learn to curl
it was a mosaic of opportunities and and
just when we thought that we'd done them
all
someone would come and staple a fresh
batch civil disobedience 101 yale photo
society fall exhibition perform with
yale children's theater conversations
with vice president al gore the silliman
haunted house is back
our camera rolls quickly turned into a
technicolor patrick of club meetings and
events and performances
but as we soon realized we just couldn't
do them all
even this year with everything that's
changed there's still so many things
that we can't do here
things that we want to do things that we
wish we had the time to do
but things that we simply can't do
the performance of our friends one
person show interferes with the ezra
styles hike to east rock
the yso concert with the ccam virtual
reality workshop
the i am spikeball tournament with the
fall foliage tour do we want free
cannolis in the courtyard
or free chicken nuggets on cross campus
do we attend the virtual college tea
with the creator of avatar the last
airbender
or with the nobel laureate even now
there's so much to do
so many people to meet and friendships
to solidify
i still think about that rainbow in
hawaii a lot though
there's just something so yale about it
from the time that we were wide-eyed
first years we've been chasing the
perfect college experience where we do
everything
take advantage of every opportunity that
yale has to offer
where by our senior springs we could be
editor-in-chief of the ydn
president of the ycc first chair of the
yso and quarterback of the football team
with four ivy league championship rings
on our finger and a diploma reading
ultra mega summa [ __ ] laude in our hands
where we've gone on every study abroad
fellowship watched and performed
in every show and met and become best
friends with everyone
we've checked off every flyer from that
bulletin board
but that's impossible it's impossible to
catch the rainbow
though if we've learned anything from
this year it's that yale isn't actually
about
catching the rainbow yells about
realizing
even if it takes four years and maybe a
pandemic
that you can never catch it and that
that's okay
yells about discovering how you want to
chase it
and it's about running and jumping and
laughing with the people you love the
entire way
because it's lovely to chase rainbows
especially when the chase is as
beautiful
and vibrant and special as it was at
yale
it can feel a little cliche to talk
about the importance of community at
yale
but the strength of those relationships
really came through in the first few
months of the pandemic
when we were so suddenly dispersed and
yet relied on each other anyway
and it was those types of moments like
playing late night fifa games with suite
mates
going on friends tours of the uag or
celebrating blowout wins against harvard
on the sports fields
which build the types of relationships
that make yale so special
and that i know can last a lifetime
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello class of 2021 and on behalf of the
class day committee
we hope you've enjoyed this virtual
version of class day and that you've
been able to experience the feelings of
camaraderie and joy
that are at the heart of this
celebration a lot has changed from our
first year to our last and i don't just
mean the pandemic that has tried to
define our senior year in one way or
another
our class has been the first to do many
things the first to live in the brand
new residential colleges that soon
became home the first to experience the
best yso halloween show ever produced
and the first to see marvin chun's
grades the class of 2021 is a group of
incredible game changers
first leapers and modernizers it's my
favorite thing about our class along
with just how incredibly passionate
strange and unique we all are in this
class day is another example
of how we get creative and incite change
in whatever we touch
the traditions ikea talked about at the
beginning are still present on this day
but we've made them our own the ivy
seeds you received are part of a long
tradition
but this year you can take them wherever
you go next
plant them in your new homes and
hopefully they'll remind you of the
incredible last four years
the anthology that we put together also
changed drastically
expanding to include different forms of
expression and hopefully encompassing as
many parts of our yale experience as
possible
one thing that hasn't changed though is
the tradition of hearing bright college
years
at the beginning and end of our time at
yale and waving the handkerchief you
received either yesterday
or even four years ago it's a
heartwarming tradition that allowed us
to say hello
and now to say goodbye therefore it's my
honor to introduce the yale glee club
in a brand new performance of bright
college years and lastly
from all of us congratulations class of
2021
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
memphis
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you